[Musique]
monsieur le ministre nous le savons tous
les réponses apportées à la question
migratoire ne peuvent être qu'européenne
dans ce contexte tendu pouvez vous
éclairer la représentation nationale sur
la situation politique en 9 en allemagne
sur l'avenir de la politique migratoire
européenne et nous assurer que la france
fera tout pour parvenir à un accord
acceptable et respecté par tous les
états membres
sinon il est à craindre un
affaiblissement de l'union européenne
que nous avons mis tant de temps à
construire
[Musique]
on s'aperçoit que alors que l'europe
avait vu un million huit cent mille
entrées régulières en 2015 en 2017
on en recense que 205 mines pourquoi
cette baisse par des accords que nous
avons passé avec un certain nombre de
pays pays de transit ou pays d'origine
c'est d'abord l'accord passé entre
l'union européenne et la turquie qui a
évidemment fait baisser de manière
considérable les entrées par la voix
orientale or je rappelle que la turquie
encore sur son territoire trois millions
cinq cent mille personnes réfugiées
c'est deuxièmement les accords que la
france a passé avec le niger qui a fait
que la route d'agadès qui voyait des
centaines de milliers de personnes
traversait le sahara puis ensuite la
méditerranée a été progressivement grâce
aux autorités nigériennes fermé aux
passeurs et enfin c'est troisièmement
les mesures qui avaient pris le ministre
de l'intérieur l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur italien marco minniti avec
un certain nombre d'autorités libyenne
pour que les passeurs soit arrêté et
c'est la première fois depuis un an et
demi que l'on voit à nouveau
effectivement des bateau chargé de
migrants
alors oui vous
j'avais raison la solution sera
européenne à l'heure au président de la
république s'insurge contre le pognon
dingue versés à nos concitoyens les plus
modestes et en appelle à la
responsabilisation des pauvres je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur ce
sujet car il est grave et mérite mieux
que des formules aussi scandaleuse que
dangereuse sur notre contrat social
cette musique droitière nous la
connaissons vous cherchez à démontrer
que les minima sociaux ne fonctionne pas
en vue de préparer les coupes
budgétaires à venir évalué à 7 milliards
par bercy c'est le montant des cadeaux
fiscaux aux plus fortunés aux plus
fortunés
focus aujourd'hui nous le savons nous
aide sociale sont inéquitables
différentes selon le statut selon l'âge
illisible c'est un maquis aucun d'entre
nous aujourd'hui une célérité
insuffisamment tournées vers
l'accompagnement
notre souci c'est de prévenir la
pauvreté à toutes les étapes de la vie
nous voulons mettre un terme à l' au
déterminisme social aux situations qui
enferme les personnes dans une activité
où est sous activité
nous ne voulons plus nous contenter
d'une politique d'insertion qui ne
permet qu'à 10 % des allocataires du rsa
de retrouver une activité chaque année
notre projet c'est bien l'efficacité et
l'investissement humain dans lequel nous
misons toutes les forces de la nation
après un an d'exercice du pouvoir le
résultat de votre politique s'avère
foncièrement injuste
vous parlez d'émancipation sociale mais
en catimini vont baisser une nouvelle
fois les apl pour les plus pauvres
vous vanter les modèles allemands et
britanniques alors que leur taux de
pauvreté est bien supérieur au nôtre
le revenu de base est un bon outil pour
lutter contre l'exclusion sociale
saisissez le
[Musique]